[Music]
this no that's too casual
nope
what's up everybody zaki here from geek
culture
hi how are you bringing you another
fantastic video
you're probably wondering what we are
doing and where we are
why am i still in my pajamas well
[Music]
what's up fella geeks zacky here from
geek culture bringing you another
fantastic video now you're probably
wondering where the hell are we
why am i still in my pajamas well
welcome to my humble abode haha
yes
and second of all why am i in my pajamas
well because i've been sleeping all day
because of this
this not not this one
this this bad boy
[Music]
very
nice this is the emma sleep original
mattress in this video we'll be testing
this mattress comparing it to my old one
which is
not good not good at all now i've been
testing this for about three months or
so and it's arguably the best
sleep experiences i've ever had
with this mattress
it's so good
and of course we have this this is my
old mattress
bucket spring matches and you know
it's not good it's it's very bad
yeah
so before i go on to my actual review of
the mattress and comparing it with my
old one
let's understand why good sleep and good
quality mattresses are important in our
daily lives
see
getting enough sleep and good quality
sleep is essential for optimal health
and well-being and not only that it's as
vital as getting regular exercise and
eating a well-balanced diet it's
probably no wonder why people like bill
gates warm buffett and even arnold make
an effort to get enough sleep regularly
we're talking about better productivity
more concentration throughout the day
you will have a better appetite and you
won't tend to munch or feel hungry
throughout the day as well of course
there's a slew of other health benefits
from getting enough sleep but of course
this is a mattress review so you know
you technically have google for that so
now when it comes to picking up a good
quality mattress of course
there are a lot of options out there
right i mean you got the different
firmness
different types of material use you got
your pocket springs you got your foam
mattresses you got your hybrid foams you
know it just gets all too confusing in
the end of the day now of course the
best way to figure out what mattress
suits your needs is to of course go to a
showroom and then test it out but that
you know you only got like what five
five minutes to land a bit you're not
even comfortable it's a crowded area
nah and you might have picked one you
might have liked one but that won't
leave you with any promises doesn't it
not to mention the exorbitant prices
that one would face
and on top of all that you know with
what's going on in the world right now i
think it's better to stay
indoors and just buy mattresses online
so in that sense a lot of mattress
companies what they do here set it off
for a sleep night trial
more than later so before we dive into
the emma original let's take a quick
look at what my previous mattress was
like wish i had a bigger home but no
right we gotta do in the living room
okay okay
all right
so this was my previous mattress
apparently it's called
apparently it's called the smart spring
mattress not so smart now isn't it
probably just a knockoff brand now the
story about this mattress is that i
recently renovated my room and you know
we managed to get a loft in there i can
finally fit a queen sized mattress so
you know because we went over budget
this is something we just picked off
online probably a decision that i really
regret it later this claims to be a
pocket coil mattress i mean you know
it's not it's not too bad right but yeah
all day what you pay is what you get so
i got this for about 250 singapore
dollars it was brand new in box and you
know if you were desperate
like me and neither the mattress real
quick oh it's it's not such a bad deal
after all was only until like a few
weeks after you know trying on this
mattress that i really did not like it
yeah
i'm pretty much thinking to myself that
how bad could it be right i was so wrong
after months and months you know instead
of being a smart
mattress uh you know it ended up giving
me more problems like backaches
pains bet
waking up in the middle of the night i
can still feel the springs like hitting
my ribs right now and it just feels like
even though i had my eight hours of
sleep i still felt tired i still felt
sluggish i just didn't want to start my
day
so drained
of your life
that's what it is so when the good folks
at
emma sleep decided to you know hey guys
uh i love your stuff let's try this
mattress for us you know i obviously i i
wanted a mattress and
here we have it
for the second time hey bro
now this is tiring yeah i had to do in
the living room there's no space
so let's talk about this mattress
this mattress is backed by sleep experts
mattress experts neuroscientists
hello there they have worked hard to
create the best sleep experience you
will ever have
or also they say you can already tell by
the look between this
and that pocket mattress that this is
some quality stuff
[Music]
this not only looks great
but it feels great too i gotta i gotta
i gotta
i don't wanna sleep no sleep
so let's dive in and take a deeper look
at the construction of this mattress so
the first thing you're going to realize
is that this is an elastic our
discussion topic
climate regulating cover of the bed
that means you don't really need a bit
[__] over this mattress really comes as
is with this cover
and not only that because of its ripples
here you know it's gonna be more
breathable now if you live in a very
humid environment very humid climate
then this top cover will help you
regulate your body temperature and the
temperature around the mattress as well
so you know that this moisture wicking
material is gonna help with that
humidity right away it's great because
it's breathable you don't feel icky or
sweaty in the morning now the other
thing about it is that the construction
of this mattress makes it great if
you're a person that moves a lot at
night now to demonstrate that
cat
and hello
yeah if you're a person that moves a lot
at night you can see
that it has minimal disturbance
when it comes
to disturbing your restless partner so
for those guys that have wives out there
or if you have a partner
he's not gonna he's not gonna run away
now speaking about that when it comes to
movement and things you're not gonna
find that this mattress will be sliding
out and things like that and that's
because instead on the underside of this
mattress there's some anti-sleep
elements there's this stuff here
surprise [__] yeah it's all nd
slip don't go under come on that being
said this is the show
the mattress doesn't slide as and when
you would like it so that's a very good
touch
from emma as well oh god
now because the bait cover is zippable
and detachable means that you can take
this out and bring it to the wash how
convenient is that guys oh well isn't
that convenient with that said this is a
25 cm deep mattress what we've got here
are three layers
with this blue layer here breathing the
breathable hyperform layer a seven zone
polyether foam for pressure relief and a
supportive point elastic foam
all this to help distribute pressure
across the mattress and comfortably
support your lower back
so it can move really
all
mind you without disturbing your partner
so what emma claims here is that the
firmness of this mattress is a medium
firm one so now that that kind of it's
pretty much the same for me in terms of
firmness i give it like a 6.5 to a seven
with 10 being the firmest and the first
time i got this i mean boy it was
surprisingly soft but that's the
funniest thing you don't get much bounce
here just because there's no coils
there's no springs on this mattress
itself and what emma claims as well is
that this
mattress is perfect for any kind of
sleeper any kind of positions
so like what what's happening now is
that i'm on my side i don't feel
pressure on my shoulders i don't feel
pressure on my hips and what this does
is that it distributes
the weight and pressure of my body onto
this mattress the match is doing that
for you you can totally see how
it's trying to make
that spinal alignment correct
and that's why i don't have any back
problems to be honest after this so
whether you're sleeping in your back if
you're sleeping on your belly if you're
sleeping aside
it all works out very well so even for
me i'm a skydiver i'm a belly flopper so
i really love to sleep
on my ballet like i love skydiving i
love this so much
but with that with the old mattress what
happens is that i get a lot of lower
back problems and that kills me every
single day ah yes
welcome to the room
uh
still still got more stuff to do
but uh we're gonna bring this mattress
up now there's one thing i want to
demonstrate is that emma sleep has
provided a
bit in a box kind of thing when it comes
out of the box it doesn't look like this
it's completely vacuum sealed and
compressed you're gonna roll it out on
the bed
and you know it'll just poof up but the
thing is emma sleep has also
created some handles here unlike other
mattresses so it's really convenient in
that sense to to put up a mattress and
it's surprisingly light
weight and i'm really emphasizing on the
word light weight but yeah we're gonna
we're gonna put this up on the loft and
it's gonna be
pretty pretty easy
because because i'm struck gonna lift it
and i've done it the wrong way we're
just gonna flip it
really small room i would like the
zipper to be on that side our
orientation is correct
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
lift this
onto our lock
oh [__] okay that didn't work how about
we use the handles no okay
oh
i did this before come on from upstairs
using the knees
we're gonna hoist
this
mattress
there we go
[__]
that
that mom
okay
i got it up
now we just need to do this
all right
there we go
now with all that good stuff of course
comes the price point it's considerably
affordable if i might add now mattresses
can be priced between anywhere from 300
to 3000
singapore dollars here and quite
surprisingly for what it's worth the
emma original matches for a queen size
one like i have here it's only priced at
799 singapore dollars better yet of
course you can go on to their website
and they're usually having sales so you
can can always get one cheaper you know
just just wait for the right time guys
you can just suffer a little bit more
doesn't matter now of course we ordered
it through the website and delivery is
pretty quick too so it takes about three
to five working days so of course with
that after sales service emma provides a
10 year warranty and you do get a 100
night sleep trial and if you're not
happy with it for some reason
not like you should be emma will refund
you what you paid and they will actually
pick it up from you for free hey i
really can't stress enough how good this
mattress is but of course don't take my
word for it you can always check out all
these reviews that will be popping up on
this screen it's generally
overwhelmingly
positive
so you're pretty much in good hands here
so should you get one for yourself
i mean it's really obvious that the emma
sleep original is a good choice it's
super comfortable and it still provides
you with that support no matter what
sleeping position you are in of course
this is also great if you have a partner
who sleeps with you sounded a bit wrong
but you know what i mean with that said
this price point of 799 singapore
dollars it's great for its value and
it's actually pretty surprising so all
you know is this a mattress you would
definitely want to consider yes well
that's all we have for this video if you
enjoyed it do give us a thumbs up and if
you have any questions as well do leave
it in the comments down below and if you
haven't already do consider subscribing
and smash that bell icon so you can be
notified every time you upload new
videos
until then this is zacky signing off
good night
hey google turn off all the lights
uh yeah
[Music]